we've discussed dark matter many times
on this channel including some
interesting facts like how there's
roughly six times more dark matter than
regular or luminous or baryonic matter
and how nobody really knows what the
dark matter is
or if it is we've even discussed
alternatives to the dark matter paradigm
alternatives that don't involve any form
of particulate matter whatsoever these
go by different names but one that we've
talked about is the so-called modified
newtonian dynamics or i say name you say
mod
there have been several incarnations of
it and several past guests on the show
including stephon alexander sabina
haasenfelder and others have looked at
alternatives to the standard particulate
wimp-based dark matter paradigm which
you've probably gotten a sense from if
you watch those videos is why
astronomers are so interested in dark
matter or perhaps what's most
fascinating is how astronomers figured
out that it even exists in the first
place
and now
it turns out what we thought we knew
about dark matter and how it helped
shape the early universe
may be
wrong altogether
as you know i'm an experimental
physicist i like doing experiments in
the lab or at the observatory
but now i'm going to ask you to do a
thought experiment you could do it in
your kitchen if you so choose if you
happen to have a toddler or a graduate
student around they may help you for
free now what would happen if you took a
glass of water and poured it on the
ground right in front of you don't pour
it on your computer some experiments are
best left to the mind alone obviously
the water spreads outwards there's
nowhere for it to really conglomerate
and accrete water spreads out such that
it minimizes the energy the potential
energy surface which would be basically
a flat plain of water molecules one
molecule thick if such a thing could
happen now way back when in our early
universe's first few minutes the
universe was a roiling boiling bubbling
brew of plasma of ordinary matter and if
dark matter exists there'd be some dark
matter in there as well
now what caused the luminous matter or
the baryonic matter to accrete to form
the structures that we use to trace the
properties of the universe today what
caused it to conglomerate and accrete in
specific locations say here but not here
why didn't all those particles spread
out uniformly throughout the universe if
that had happened we wouldn't even be
here to ask a question about the
characteristics of the early universe
there'd be nowhere for matter to form
and that matter needed to form in order
to form stars individual stars and then
individual galaxies and eventually
clusters of galaxies so water or any
other fluid flows in a way that
minimizes their potential energy surface
it would work the same way if water were
poured out so to speak in space it would
just float away in a minimum energy
surface which would be a sphere but a
sphere of constant density now
astronomers make the simplification
that you can actually trace the
distribution of matter luminous matter
the matter that we can see we can't see
dark matter after all at least not yet
and maybe not ever if it doesn't exist
but astronomers can approximate galaxies
as basically individual water molecules
if you like in a fluid and then the
whole aggregate set of those galaxies
taken together is like the glass of
water to begin with
and you can ask a question if there were
galaxies point particles in the
simulation in the early universe
uniformly distributed something must
have caused them to form giant clumps
rather than just dispersing evenly over
the flat cosmic floor it's a huge
mystery heading back to the kitchen get
yourself a muffin tray the muffin man
muffin man and take the glass of water
and pour it onto the muffin tray what
will happen is most of the water will
accumulate in the indentations in the
muffin tray the muffins themselves i'm
getting hungry just thinking about this
get in my belly
there'll be a little bit on the
interstices between the individual cups
where the muffins will eventually form
in this analogy the floor or the muffin
tray is the background space tone
where the space time is uniform in a
flat floor you have no place for the
matter to accumulate with the muffin
tray there are lower energy surfaces the
cups in the indentations in the muffin
tray itself where the water will seek
out a lower level where there's more
matter there's more gravity not just
with muffin trays but in the early
universe as well so if the early
universe had some sort of indentation in
its space-time curvature
then it would provide a place for
ordinary baryonic or luminous matter to
accumulate to then form stars clusters
of galaxies etc we've spoken in previous
videos about how spacetime can receive
curvature on small scales in fact that's
one of the many successes of the
inflationary paradigm though other
models of cosmogenesis like bouncing
cosmological models can do that as well
so cosmologists speak about curvature
fluctuations and where those curvature
fluctuations come from is a matter of
another mystery but the fact that the
curvature of space-time is tantamount to
a gravitational force field is
established in einstein's equivalence
principles so
once the curvature perturbations are
established there'll be a place for
baryonic matter to form and that will
form where there was already dark matter
accumulating earlier on in the
universe's history the paradigm is
there's something that causes a
fluctuation in curvature which is
tantamount to a increased or decreased
gravitational potential which causes
dark matter to form and to cluster and
clump in a special regions of the
universe as opposed to spreading out
evenly and then the gravity of the dark
matter attracts the luminous baryonic
matter that we can see that's the
paradigm of so-called cold dark matter
cosmology that established and has
established so long the paradigm that we
look at and we study the early universe
but what if you found a massive object
of ordinary matter
in the middle of space
that had no dark matter
that would be a huge challenge the
antagonist in today's mystery is the
recent discovery of a galaxy without
dark matter
a few years ago astronomers led by
yale's peter van delkham and others
discovered a galaxy with no dark matter
this dark matter free galaxy
goes by the very very evocative name of
ngc 105
for the sake of just our conversation
amongst friends i'll just call it 1052
or 1052 for sure through their
measurements they discovered that the
gravity produced by this galaxy could be
accounted for
solely by its luminous matter content
alone that is just the mere baryons that
we see in this galaxy were sufficient to
explain its gravitational properties to
put that into context
in the milky way we astronomers believe
that our galaxy is comprised of about 84
percent dark matter and about 16
ordinary or luminous matter and most of
that luminous matter is in the form of
hydrogen and helium and the light
elements on the periodic table and just
a tiny smidgen of which is the cosmic
schmutz that makes us up
so to see a galaxy like
1052 with so little dark matter is a
challenge to the cold dark matter
paradigm
this galaxy is exceedingly faint
in the first images the team looked at
from way back when in the year 2000 it
wasn't much more than a blip in the
background of galactic cosmic wallpaper
that the team had looked at
since then
thanks to images from a host of other
observatories and even the hubble space
telescope
astronomers have finally been able to
see it in enough detail to examine this
galaxy's properties precisely
and what they saw in galaxy 1052 is
quite astounding they didn't only use
the stars within the galaxy itself
they actually saw a swarm of small blobs
orbiting around the blip which was once
observed in its entirety to be this
galaxy 1052.
now these blobs have been known for
quite some time and they played a big
role in the history of cosmology both in
our galaxy and in other galaxies they're
called globular clusters
they're global i.e spherical globe shape
distributions of stars
that are usually comprised of about a
hundred thousand to maybe a few hundred
thousand individual stars
living in such a globular cluster would
be a nightmare because it would never
get dark you'd have stars surrounding
you in all directions these globular
clusters in the early 1920s played a
specific role in our understanding of
the structure of the universe providing
evidence that the sun was not located at
the exact center of the milky way galaxy
that's a topic i discuss in my video
called the great debate these cosmic
fireflies swarming around a firefly hive
are useful to astronomers because they
can check how the gravity field of the
individual galaxy
is pulling on these orbiting almost like
satellites surrounding the larger host
galaxy in this case 1052 and astronomers
looked at those globular clusters around
1052 what they saw was that the behavior
their orbital velocities and their
properties of the globular clusters
could be accounted for exactly by the
mass produced by the luminous
light producing baryonic matter of 1052
alone so suggest that there's no dark
matter or it's certainly not a
substantial amount of dark matter as
there is in the milky way galaxy this
shouldn't be found in the so-called cold
dark matter paradigm or cdn paradigm so
it comes as a challenge and it has to be
rectified and addressed this discovery
could have some very far-reaching
consequences if it holds up particulate
dark matter dark matter that's comprised
of wimps weakly interacting massive
particles is not universally accepted no
pun intended
some people say that there are unseen
forces that cause the nucleation of
galaxies to form almost like a fine
tuning of galaxy formation they provide
the holes in the muffin tray without
requiring dark matter to seed and cause
the depth of the potential gravitational
potential well
so our antagonist 1052 stands as a
challenge to the accretion model wherein
dark matter causes luminous matter to
accrete onto it because you have a
galaxy that has almost no dark matter so
it should be impossible in that paradigm
for this galaxy to exist or it could be
something has stripped
the galaxy of just its dark matter so
that would require some contrivances
we'd have to think of a mechanism
through which the dark matter could get
stripped away and completely rendered
invisible to these astronomers
telescopes or it could indicate that
galaxies can form on sort of the
interstices between the muffin trays and
depressions
and in a way that wasn't thought
statistically likely beforehand
so
if dark matter is responsible for the
formation of galaxies and clusters of
galaxies how did this galaxy get by
without it of course astronomers are
incredibly creative and there are many
theories as to how this could occur even
in the cdm paradigm
perhaps another galaxy stole a bunch of
dark matter away from 1052 like a cosmic
hamburglar stealing the muffin top buns
or maybe this galaxy's current
appearance is the result of a collision
wherein a bunch of the ordinary matter
in the galaxy got knocked away
forming sort of a mini galaxy devoid of
any dark matter now both of these
theories have plenty of challenges in
order to address them and it's not known
if 1052 got knocked away from its dark
matter halo so to speak from a big
galactic collision if it did
there should be some scars some shrapnel
left over from the collision of two more
massive galaxies perhaps a tail a
streamer of stars tracing back to the
scene of the collision the only thing we
know for sure is that if we can get a
better look at 1052 we'll get a much
better idea of what's going on similar
to how the first early ground-based
telescopic images of it really only just
revealed it as a tiny blip of light and
then the hubble space telescope and
larger ground-based telescopes revealed
it in more and more detail
how did a galaxy seemingly emerge into
existence without any
dark matter to seed it with the web
telescope astronomers could track the
individual orbits of stars within the
dark matter-less galaxy instead of just
looking at the blobs the globular
clusters orbiting around it now 1052 is
hardly the only controversial
adversarial
antagonistic character in the dark
matter dynamical story in contra
distinction to 1052 there's a galaxy
called dragonfly 44.
it has a lot more dark matter in it than
astronomers would have ever expected
completely the opposite of 1052 as we
discussed with governor schilling and
his wonderful new book called the
elephant in the universe 100 years of
studying dark matter link in the video
description
as time progresses we'll get more and
better data on galaxies like these two
outliers and that will help us refine
and understand the role and even the
existence of particulate dark matter
cosmologists are hungry for more data
waiting for the next breakthrough from
futuristic surveys and certainly we'll
learn a lot more about dark matter as
soon as these data come in until then
i'll pass the time by eating a muffin if
you liked this video i created a
playlist just for you all about dark
matter including my interviews with
gilbert shelling mutty milgram and
others and if you'd like to watch a
video about what astronomers already
know about dark matter from the only
form of particulate dark matter that we
know for sure exists in neutrino click
on this video and don't forget to
subscribe